the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
today we're going to continue our
discussion I'm going to continue our
discussion of methods of integration the
method that I'm going to describe to Zay
today handles a whole class of functions
of the following form you take G of X
divided by Q of X and this is known as a
rational function and all that means is
that it's a ratio of two polynomials
which are these functions P of X and Q
of X will handle all such functions by a
method which is known as partial
fractions and what this does is it
splits P over Q into what you could call
easier pieces all right so that's going
to be some kind of algebra and that's
what we're going to spend most of our
time doing today I'll start with an
example and all of my examples will be
illustrating more general methods the
example is to integrate the function 1
over X minus 1 plus say 3 over X plus 2
DX now that's that's easy to do it's
just we already know the answer its
natural log of X minus 1 plus 3 times
natural log of X plus 3 plus a constant
so that's done ok
so now here's the difficulty that is
going to arise the difficulty is that I
can start with this function which is
perfectly manageable and then I can add
these two functions together the way I
do the way I add fractions so that's
getting a common denominator and so that
gives me X plus 2 here plus 3 times X
minus 1 and now if I combine together
all of these terms then altogether I
have 4x plus 2 minus 3 that's I guess
minus 1 and then if I multiply out the
denominator that's x squared plus o
that's who turned into a 3 that's
interesting I hope there aren't too many
more of those transformations is there
another one here oh that happened
earlier on wow that's an interesting
vibration there okay thank you
all right so I guess yeah my my 3s were
speaking to my twos somewhere in my past
huh okay all right anyway I think this
is now correct okay so so the problem is
the following this is the problem with
this this integral was easy right I'm
calling it easy we already know how to
do it over here but now over here it's
it's disguised it's the same function
but it's no longer clear how to
integrate it if you're faced with this
one you say what am I supposed to do and
we have to get around that difficulty
and so what we're going to do is we're
going to unwind
this disguise so we have the the algebra
problem that we have oh wow there must
be something in the water and impressive
Wow okay let's see is 2/3 equal to
three-halves holy cow
alright well that's good well I'll keep
you awake today with several other
transpositions here okay so our algebra
problem is to is to detect the easy
pieces which are inside inside in the
and the end of method that we're going
to use the one that will emphasize
anyway is one algebraic trick which is
which is a shortcut which is called the
cover-up method but we're going to talk
about even more general things than that
but anyway this is where we're headed is
something called the cover-up method all
right so that's our intro and I'll just
have to remember the two is not three
I'll keep on repeating that all right so
now here I'm going to describe to you
how we unwind this this disguise the
first step is we write down the function
we want to integrate which was this and
now we have to undo the first damage
that we did so the first step is to
factor the denominator and that factors
we happen to know the factors so I'm not
going to carry this out but this can be
a rather difficult step but we're going
to assume that it's done for the
purposes of illustration here so i
factor the denominator and now the
second thing that i'm going to do is
what i'm going to call the set up here
how i'm going to set things up and i'll
tell you what these things are more
matically in a second and the setup is
that I want to somehow detect what I did
before and I'm going to write some
unknowns here what I expect is that this
will break up into two pieces one with a
denominator X minus one on the other
with the denominator X plus two okay so
now my third step is going to be to
solve for a and B and then I'm done if I
do that that's the complete unwinding of
this disguise and this is where the
cover-up method comes in handy this is
this this method that I'm about to
describe now you can do the algebra in a
clumsy way or you can do it in a quick
way and we'd like to get efficient about
the algebra involved and so let me show
you what the what the first step in the
trick is we're going to solve for a by
multiplying by X minus 1 now notice if
you multiply by X minus 1 in that
equation 2 what you get is this you get
4x minus 2 divided by the X minus 1s
cancel you get this on the left hand
side and on the right hand side you get
a the X minus 1s cancel again and then
we get this extra term which is B times
X plus 2 times X minus 1 now the trick
here and we're going to get even better
trick in just a second the trick here is
that I didn't try to clear the
denominators completely I was very
efficient about the way I did it I just
cleared one factor and the result here
is very useful namely if I plug in now x
equals 1 this term drops out - all right
so what I'm going to do now is I'm going
to plug in x equals 1
and what I get on the left-hand side
here is 4 minus 1 and 1 plus 2 and on
the left-hand side I get a that's the
end all right this is my formula for a a
happens to be equal to 1 and that's of
course what I expect a had better be 1
because the thing broke up into 1 over X
minus 1 plus 3 over X plus 2 so this is
this is the correct answer there was a
question out here which I yeah
polynomials defined this functions with
whole powers or divinity square roots
our polynomial is defined as functions
with whole powers or can they be square
roots that's the question the answer is
they only have whole powers so for
instance here I only have the power 1
and 0 here I have the powers to 1 and 0
in the denominator square roots are no
good for this method another question
why x equals 1 the reason why I said x
equals 1 was that it works really fast
you can't know this in advance that's
part of the method all right it just
turns out to be the best thing to do the
fastest way of getting at the
coefficient a now the curious thing let
me just pause for a second before I do
it if I had plugged x equals 1 into the
original equation I would have gotten
nonsense because I would have gotten 0
in the denominator and that he seems
like the most horrible thing to do the
worst possible thing to do is to set x
equals to 1 on the other hand what we
did is a trick we multiplied by X minus
1 and that turned the equation into this
so now in disguise I multiplied by 0 but
that turns out to be legitimate because
what really this equation is true for
all X except 1 and then instead of
taking x equals 1 I can really take X
tends to 1 that's really what I mean the
limit as X goes to 1 the equation is
still valid then so I'm using the worst
case the case that looks like it's
dividing by 0
and it's helping me because it's
cancelling out all the information in
terms of B so that the advantage here is
this cancellation that occurs on in this
part all right so that's the method
we're going to shorten it much much more
in a second but let me carry it out for
the other coefficient as well so the
other coefficient I'm going to solve for
solve for B I'm going to multiply by X
plus 2 and when I do that I get 4x minus
1 divided by X minus 1 that's the
left-hand side the very top expression
there and then down below I get a times
X minus 1 times X plus 2 and then again
the B the the X plus 2's cancel so I get
B sitting alone and now I'm going to do
the same trick I'm going to set x equals
negative 2 that's the value where the
which is going to knock out this a term
here so that cancels this term
completely and what we get here all told
is minus 8 minus 1 divided by minus 2
minus 1 is equal to B in other words B
equals 3 which was also what it was
supposed to be B was this number 3 right
here which I'm now not going to change
to 2 because I know that it's not two
there was a question all right
all right now this is the method which
is called cover-up but it's really
carried out much much faster than this
so I'm going to review the method and
I'm going to show you what it is in
general so the first step is to factor
the denominator Q that's what I labeled
one over there that was the
factorization of the denominator up top
the second step is what I'm going to
call the set up that's step two and
that's where I knew what I was aiming
for in advance and I'm going to have to
explain to you in every instance exactly
what the set up should be that is what
the unknowns should be and what target a
simplified expression we're aiming for
so that's the set up and then the third
step is what I'll now call cover-up
which is just a very fast way of doing
what I did on this last board which is
solving for the unknown coefficients so
now let me perform it for you again over
here so it's 4 X minus 1 divided by so
this is this is to eliminate writing
here hand writing it makes it much
faster so this part just factoring the
denominator that was that was one that
was step one and then step two again is
the set up which is setting it up like
this all right that's the set up and now
I claim that without writing very much I
can figure out what a and B are just by
staring at this so now what I'm going to
do is I'm just going to think what I did
over there and I'm just going to do it
directly so that so let me show you what
the the method consists of visually I'm
going to cover up that is knock out this
factor and focus on this number here
and I'm going to plug in the thing that
makes this zero which is x equals one so
I'm plugging in x equals one to this
left hand side and what I get is four
minus one divided by one plus two is
equal to ay all right now that's the
same thing I did over there I just did
it with by skipping the intermediate
algebra step which is a lot of writing
so the cover-up method really amounts to
the following thing I'm thinking of
multiplying this over here it cancels
this and it gets rid of everything else
and it just leaves me with a on the
right-hand side and I have to get rid of
it on this side so in other words by
eliminating this I am isolating a on the
right-hand side so the cover-up is that
I'm covering this and getting a out of
it similarly I can do the same thing
with B it's focused on the the value x
equals -2 and B is what I'm getting on
the right-hand side and then I have to
cover up this alright so if I cover up
that then what's left over with x equals
-2 is again minus 8 minus 1 divided by
minus 2 minus 1 all right so this is the
way the method gets carried out in
practice writing essentially the the
least you can now when you get to
several variables it becomes just way
more convenient to do this so now let me
just review when cover-up works so this
cover-up method works if Q of X has
distinct linear factors and so you need
two things here it has to factor
completely the denominator has to factor
completely and the degree of the
numerator has to be strictly less than
the degree of the denominator
I'm going to give you an example here so
for instance and this tells you the
general pattern of the of the set up
also say you had x squared plus 3x plus
8 let's say over X minus 1 times X minus
2 times X plus 5 so here I'm going to
tell you the set up the set up is going
to be a over X minus 1 plus B over X
minus 2 plus C over X plus 5 and it will
always break up into something so no
matter many factors you have you'll have
to put in a term for each of those and
then you can find each number here by
this cover-up method
now we're done with that and now we have
to go on to the algebraic complications
so what would the first typical
algebraic complication be it would be
repeated roots or repeated factors let
me get one that doesn't come out to be
extremely ugly here so this is what
we'll call example two and this is going
to work when the degree you'll always
need that the degree of the numerator is
less than the degree of the denominator
and Q has now repeated linear factors so
let's see which example I wanted to to
show you so let's just give this here
I'll just repeat the the the denominator
with with an extra factor like this now
the main thing you need to know since
I've already performed the factorization
for you've already already performed
step one this is step one here you have
to factor things all the way and it's
that's already been done for you and
here's what the setup is the setup is
that it's of the form a over X minus one
plus B over X minus one squared we need
another term for the square here plus C
over X plus two in general if you have
more powers you just need to keep on
putting in those powers you need all one
for each of the powers well why does it
have to be squared okay so a good
question so why in the world am I doing
this let me just give you one hint as to
why I'm doing this
okay it's very very much like the
decimal expansion of a number or say the
base two expansion of a number so for
example the number seven 16 is 0 over 2
plus 1 over 2 squared plus a 1 over 2
cubed plus that right so it's 4 16 s
plus 2 so 2 plus 1 over 2 to the fourth
it's this sort of thing and I'm getting
this power in this power if I have
higher powers I'm going to have to have
more and more so this is what happens
when I have a 2 to the fourth I'll have
to represent things like this that's
that's what's coming out of this piece
with the repetitions here of the powers
this is just an analogy with what we're
doing yeah another question over here
yes so this is an example but it's meant
to represent to the general case and I
will also give you a general picture for
sure once you have the second power here
you'll need both the first and the
second power mentioned over here and
since there's only a first power over
here I only have to mention a first
power over there if this were a 3 here
there would be one more term which would
be the one for X minus 1 cubed in the
denominator that that's what you just
said okay now what's different about
this setup is that the cover-up method
although it works it doesn't work so
well it doesn't work quite as well a
cover-up
works for the coefficients B and C not a
but we will have a quick method for the
numbers B and C to figure out what they
are but it will be a little slower to
get to a which we will do last
let me show you how it works first of
all I'm going to do the ordinary
cover-up with C so for C I just want to
do the same old thing that I did before
I cover up this and that's going to get
rid of all the junk except for the C
term so I have to plug in x equals
negative 2 and I get X sorry I get minus
2 squared plus 2 in the numerator and I
get minus 2 minus 1 the quantity squared
in the denominator remember I'm covering
this up so that's all there is on the
left-hand side and on the right-hand
side all there is is see everything else
got killed off because it was X minus 2
times I've had 0 times all that other
stuff and the X minus 2 over here
cancelled this is the shortcut that I
just described and this is much faster
than doing all that arithmetic and
algebra so altogether this is a 6 over
over 9 right so it's it's C is equal to
6 over 9 which is 2/3 now the other one
which is easy to do I'm going to do by
the slow method first but there's a that
you can omit a term the idea is to cover
up the other bad factor cover up so I'll
do it both of the fast way and a slow
way I'll do it the fast way first and
then I'll show you the slow way the fast
ways to cover this up and then I have to
cover up everything else that gets
eliminated and that includes everything
but B so I get B on this side and I get
1 on that side so that's 1 squared plus
2 divided by 1 plus 2 so in other words
B is equal to 1
that was pretty fast so let me show you
what arithmetic was hiding behind that
what algebra was hiding behind it what I
was really doing is this and multiplying
through by X minus 1 squared so I got
this
so this cancelled here so this B just
stands stands alone and then I have here
see X plus 2 X minus 1 squared notice
again I cleared out that one this term
from the denominator and sent it over to
the other side
now what's happening is that when I set
x equals 1 here this term is dying this
term is going away because there's more
powers in the numerator than in the
denominator this is still 0 and this one
is gone also so all that's left is B now
I cannot pull that off with a single
power of X minus 1 I can't expose the a
term it's the B term that I can expose
because I can multiply through by this
thing squared
if I multiply through by just X minus 1
what will happen here is I won't have
canceled this X minus 1 squared it's
useless I still have a 0 in the
denominator of B over 0 when I plug in x
equals 1 which I can't use again the
cover-up method is giving us B and C not
not a all right now for the last term
for a I'm going to just have to be a
straightforward about it and so I'll
just suggest for a plug in your favorite
number so plug in my favorite number
which is x equals zero you won't be able
to plug in x equals zero if you've
already used it here the two numbers
we've already used are x equals 1 and x
equals -2 but we haven't used x equals
zero yet so that's good I'm going to
plug in now x equals zero into the
equation what do I get I get 0 squared
plus 2 divided by minus 1 squared times
2 is equal to let's see a is the thing
that I don't know so it's a over
negative 1 plus B over X minus 1 squared
so B is 1 so that's 1 over minus 1
squared and then C was 2/3 2/3 over X
plus 2 so that's 0 plus 2 don't don't
give up at this point this is a lot of
algebra you really have to plug in all
these numbers right you make one
arithmetic mistake and you're always
going to get the wrong answer this is
very arithmetic alee intensive however
it does simplify at this point we have 2
over 2 that's 1 is equal to negative a
plus 1 plus 1/3 so let's see a on the
other side this becomes a is equal to
1/3 and that's it this is this is the
end we've we've simplified our our
function and now it's easy to integrate
question another question
yeah so the question is if you if x
equals zero has already been used what
do I do and the answer is I pick
something else and you said pick a
random number and that's that's right
accept it if you really picked a random
number it would be four point one two
five six seven eight four three which
would be difficult what you want to
prove because the easiest possible
number you can think of yeah if you had
as in as in this sort of situation here
more more powers wouldn't you have more
variables very good question
that's absolutely right this was a 3 by
3 system in disguise for these three
unknowns a B and C what we started with
in the previous problem was two
variables so over here the variables a
and B and as the degree of the
polynomial the number of variables goes
up it gets more and more and more
complicated more and more arithmetic
aliy intensive well so the question is
how would you solve it if you have two
unknowns that's exactly the point here
we this is a system of simultaneous
equations four unknowns and we have
little tricks for isolating single
variables otherwise we're stuck with
solving the whole system then you'd have
to solve the whole system by elimination
various other tricks all right as I say
I'll say a little more about that later
now I'm going to get I have to get one
step more complicated
with my next example my next example is
going to have a quadratic factor so
still I'm sticking to the degree of the
polynomial ax numerator is less than the
degree of the polynomial in the
denominator and I'm going to take the
case where Q has a quadratic factor let
me just again illustrate this by example
I have here X minus 1 x squared plus 1
I'll make it about as easy as they come
now the setup will be slightly different
here here's the set up it's already
factored I've already done as much as I
can do I can't factor this x squared
plus 1 into linear factors unless you
know about complex numbers if you know
about complex numbers this method
becomes much easier and it comes back to
the cover-up method which is the way
that the cover-up method was originally
conceived by Heaviside but you won't get
to that until 1803 so we'll wait this by
the way is a method which is used for
integration but it was invented to do
something with Laplace transforms and
inversion of certain kinds of
differential equations by Heaviside and
he that's so it came much later than
integration but anyway it's a very
convenient method ok so here's the set
up with this one again we want a term
for this X minus 1 factor and now we're
going to also have a term with the
denominator x squared plus 1 but this is
the difference it's now going to be a
first degree polynomial one degree down
from the quadratic here
right so this is what I've been keep on
calling the setup this is number two
you have to know that in advance based
on the pattern that you see on the left
hand side yes if the degree of numerator
is equal to that the denominator is this
none of this works the question is if
the degree of the numerator so in this
case of the degree of the numerator if
this were cubed and this is matching
with the denominator which is total of
degree three the answer is that this
does not work it definitely doesn't work
and we're going to have to do something
totally different to handle it which
turns out fortunately to be much easier
than this but we will deal with that at
the end all right so you see keep keep
this in mind this is an easy way to make
a mistake if you start with a higher
degree numerator you'll never get the
right answer all right so now let's so I
have my setup now and now what can I do
well I claim that I can still do
cover-up for a it's the same idea I
cover this guy up and if I really
multiply by it it would knock everything
out but a so I cover this up and I plug
in x equals 1 so I get here 1 squared
divided by 1 squared plus 1 is equal to
a in other words is equal to 1/2 again
cover-up is pretty fast as you can see
it's not it's not too bad
now at this next stage
I want to find B and C and the best idea
is the slow way here it's not too
terrible but it's just what we're going
to do which is to clear the denominators
completely so for B and C just clear the
denominator that means multiply through
by by that whole business now when you
do that on the left hand side you're
going to get x squared because I got rid
of the whole denominator on the right
hand side when I bring this up the X
minus 1 will cancel with this so the a
term will be a times x squared plus 1
and the beat BX plus C term will have a
remaining factor of X minus 1 because
the x squared plus 1 will cancel again
the arithmetic here is not too terrible
now I'm going to do the following I mean
a look at the x squared term on the left
hand side and the right hand side and
that will give me one equation for B and
C and then I'm going to do the same
thing with another term the x squared
term on the left hand side the
coefficient is 1 it's 1 times x squared
on the other side it's a but remember I
actually have a so I'm going to put it
in its 1/2 all right so this is the a
term and so I get 1/2 times x squared
and then the only other x squared is
when this B X multiplies this X so be x
times X is be x squared so this is the
other coefficient on on x squared is B
and that forces B to be 1/2
and last of all I'm going to do the X to
the zero power term or otherwise known
as the constant term and on the left
hand side the constant term is zero
there is no constant term on the right
hand side there's a constant term 1/2
times 1 that's 1/2 here and then there's
another constant term which is this
constant times this minus 1 which is
minus C and so the conclusion here is
that C is equal to 1/2 another question
yeah
there's there's also an X to the zero
power hidden in there
here I'm sorry next to the one power
that's what you were asking about sorry
there's also next to the one power the
only reason why I didn't go to the X to
the 1 power is that it turns out with
these two I didn't need it the other
thing is that by experience I know that
the extreme ends of the multiplication
or the easiest ends and the middle terms
have tons of cross terms and so I don't
like the middle term as much because it
always involves more arithmetic so I
stick to the lowest and the highest
terms if I can so I was that was really
a sneaky thing I just I did that without
without saying anything
yes another good question
could I just set x equals zero
absolutely in fact that's equivalent to
picking out the x to the zero term and
you could plug in numbers if you wanted
that's another way of doing this besides
doing doing that so you can also plug in
numbers can plug in numbers x levels
zero actually not x equals 1 right minus
1 2 etc not 1 just because we've already
used it we won't get interesting
information out yes the next condition
put that one in my head yeah so the
question is could I have done it this
this other way with the polynomial with
this with this other one yes absolutely
so in other words what I've taught you
now is to two choices which are equally
reasonable it the one that I picked was
the one that was the fastest for this
net guy and the one that was fastest for
this one but I could have done the other
way around yeah so there there are a lot
of ways of solving simultaneous
equations yeah another question the
question is the following so now
everybody can understand the question
it's if this instead of being x squared
plus 1 this were X cubed plus 1 all
right so that's an important case to
understand that's a case in which this
this denominator is not fully factored
so it's an X cube plus 1 you would have
to factor out an x plus
all right so that would be a situation
like this you have an X cubed plus one
but that's X plus one times x squared
plus X plus one this kind of thing if
that's the right there must be minus
sign in here maybe okay something like
this right isn't that what it is
I think that's right but anyway the
point is you have to factor it all right
and then you have a linear in a
quadratic so that you're always going to
be faced eventually with linear and
linear factors and quadratic factors if
you have a cubic that means you haven't
factored sufficiently so you're still
back in step one in the X cubed plus one
case in the X cubed plus one case we are
out of luck until we've completed the
factorization once we've completed the
factorization we're going to have to
deal with these two factors as
denominators okay so it'll be it'll be
this plus something over X plus ones
plus BX plus C type of thing over this
this thing here that's what's eventually
going to happen all right but but hold
on to that idea let me let me carry out
one more example here all right so I
figured out what all the the values are
but I think it's also worth it to
remember now that we also have to carry
out the integration
what I've just shown you is that the
integral of x squared DX over X minus
one times x squared plus one is equal to
and I've split it up into these pieces
so what are the pieces the pieces are
1/2 X minus 1 plus 1/2 x over x squared
plus 1 right this is the a term this is
the B term and then there's the C term
so we better remember that we know how
to anti-differentiate these things and
as in other words I want to finish the
problem the others were pretty easy so I
didn't bother to finish my sentence but
here I want to be careful and have you
realized that there's something a little
more to do first of all we have the
first one is no problem that's that's
this the second one actually is not too
bad either
this is by the advanced guessing method
my favorite method something like the
logarithm because that's what's going to
appear in the denominator and then if
you differentiate this you're going to
get 2x over this but here we have 1/2 so
altogether it's 1/4 of this all right
so I fixed the coefficient here and then
the last one you have to think back to
some level of memorization here and
remember that this is 1/2 the arctangent
all right
why did I go to a quarter because in
disguise for this guy I was thinking D
by DX of natural log of x squared plus 1
is 2x over x squared plus 1 because it's
the derivative of this divided by itself
that's the right this is the derivative
of log U as u prime over u log u prime
equals u prime over u that was the what
I applied and what I had was a half so I
need a total of 1/4 to cancer so two
fourths is one half all right now I got
to get you out of one more deep hole and
I'm going to save the general pattern
for next time but I do want to clarify
one thing
so let's let's handle this thing what if
the degree of P is bigger than or equal
to the degree of Q that's the that's the
thing that I claimed was easier and I'm
going to describe to you how it's done
now in analogy with numbers you might
call this an improper fraction that's
the that's the thing that it should echo
in your mind when you're thinking about
this and I'm just going to do it by
example here let's see I cooked up an
example so that I don't make an
arithmetic mistake along the way so
there are two or three steps that I need
to explain so here's an example the
denominator is degree 2 the numerator is
degree 3 it well exceeds so there's a
problem here our method is not going to
work and the first step that I want to
carry out is to reverse step one that is
I don't want the factorization for what
I'm going to do next
I want it multiplied out that means I
have to multiply through so I get x
squared plus X minus 2 now I'm back to
the starting place here alright and now
the next thing that I'm going to do is
I'm going to use long division that's
how you convert an improper fraction to
a proper fraction this is something you
were supposed to learn in in I don't
know grade 4 Greg no I know grade 3
grade 4 grade 5 6 etc ok so here's how
it works in the case of polynomials it's
kind of amusing so we're dividing we're
dividing this polynomial into that one
and so the quotient to first-order here
is X that is that's going to match the
top terms so I get X cubed plus x
squared minus 2x
that's the product and now I subtract
and it cancels so we get here minus x
squared plus 2x that's the difference
and now I need to divide this next term
in and I need a minus one all right
so minus one times this is minus x
squared minus X plus two and I subtract
and the X Squared's cancel and here I
get plus 3x minus 2 ok now this thing
has a name this is called the quotient
and this thing also has a name this is
called the remainder and now I'll show
you how it works by sticking it in to
the answer here the quotient is X minus
1 and the remainder is let's get down
there
3x minus 2 divided by x squared plus X
minus 2 all right so the punchline here
is that this thing is easy to integrate
right this is easy and this one you can
use now you can use cover up the method
that we had before because the degree of
the numerator is now below the degree of
the denominator it's now first degree
and this is second degree what you can't
do is use cover up to start out with
here that will give you the wrong answer
alright so that's the end for today
and see you next time